♪ ♪ ♪
- La vallée du Mojave surnommée
la vallée de la mort à cause
Un paysage dramatique qui nous
rappelle des films iconiques
encore les westerns.
(grondement de tonnerre)
Il y a des éclairs, mais très
peu de pluie, le mercure indique
en moyenne 40 degrés.
Au loin, un mirage, un oasis.
Et non, ce sont des milliers
de panneaux solaires qui nous
au 21e siècle et que la planète
a besoin d'autres solutions
pour poursuivre sa cadence. Le t
le lac Mead, principale source
d'eau dans la région, tout près
du Nevada. Ce lac artificiel,
créé par le barrage Hoover,
détonne avec le paysage
désertique. Il disparaît
presque sous nos yeux
"Je suis inquiet, dit-il
devrions nous quitter Vegas?
Est-ce qu'il va nous manquer
d'eau? Personne n'y croit.
Je prie pour plus de neige."
"Ceci nour
les  bateaux, dit sa fille.
Car jadis, il y avs, il y avs, t
huit marinas. Il n'en reste
plus que deux."
En plein désert, une communauté
de plaisanciers s'
maintenant.
"Nous ades bateaux,
dit-il, mais on ne peut plus
les mettre à l'en'y a
plus de rampe, il n'en reste
qu'une, et les files d'attente
sont de 4 à 5 heures la fin
Le lac Mead est lis.is.is.is.i.
Il approvisionne en eau et
ricité le Nevada,
l'Arizona, la Californie.
Il est à son niveau le plus bas
de non-retour.
"Cet été, le niveau baissait
de 30 cm par semaine, dit-elle.
C'était choquant."
Jocelyne et Bill vingtaine
d'années. Le niveau de l'eau abe
en témoigne ce rocher, la partie
blanche était submAujourd'huAuja
une profondeur d'à peine plus
de 300 m, ce qui pourrait ê
de l'eau, le lac a révélé
ses secrets les plus sordides;
des cadavres ont refait surface,
des corps retrouvés dans l'eau
de l'époque nous dit-on, car
elle contrôlait les casinos.
en cours.
Moins de pluie, moins de ne
le fleuve du Colorado, qui prent
qui alimente le barrage Hoover.
"Lorsque le niveau de l'eau vas
générer de l'électricité."
40 millions de personnesdans Ét
de ce fleuve en électricité
et en eau.
Chip Sherrill est un fermier
de l'Arizona, juste à la
frontière du Nevada.
(ruissellement d'eau)
80 % de l'eau puisée dans
le  fleuve est utilisée
par les fermiers.
"C'est une méga sécheresse,Je a
en 45 ans, le fleuve avec
un débit aussi faible."
"Je suis très inquiet, dit-il.
C'est toute ma vie. En 2023,
ils vont couper 21 % de
notre approvisionnement en eau.
S'il n'y a pas de compensati
les fermes vont s'assécher,
et c'est notre gagne-pain."
Il cultive entre autre
la luzer
de la moitié de ses terres
sont en jachère.
"Nous vivons dans le désert,
il faut agir en conséquence,
nous dit Damon Hodge,
porte parole de l'agence de
conservation de l'eau au Nevada.
"Chaque utilisate
devra prendre des décisions
difficiles, douloureuses
pour l'avenir."
Et l'État prend ces moyens.
Dès 6 h du matin, la police
de l'eau parcourt le sud
du Nevada pour s'assurer qu'il
n'y ait pas de gaspillage.
Interdic
11 h et 19 h, et pas plus
de trois jours par semaine,e dit
s'assurer que l'eau ne coule
pas inutilement impunément
dans la rue.
"La première ame
de 80 dollars, dit-il. Et si
ce n'est pas corrigé, on double
l'amende et ainsi de suite."
Toute l'eau utilisée
à l'intérieur des maisons est
récupérée et recyclée.
Et puis on encourage
la population à se débarrassere.
"On s'est débarassé de près
de 20 km2 de pelouse, dit il,
et avons économisé 617 milliards
de litres d'eau.
"Nous avons encore beaucoup
de gazon, dit-elle
il va falloir enlever
tout ça d'ici 2026."
Le Nevada agit en bon élève
dans la région, à cause
des efforts depuis 20 ans
pour la conservation de l'eau.
Malgré t23,
l'État devra réduire
sa consommation d'eau de 8 %,
l'Arizona de 21 % et le Mexiquet
épargnée pour le moment,
ce qui crée des tensions.
"La Californie ne doit pas
réduire son approvisionnement,pt
beaucoup d'eau. Tout le monde
doit être vigilant. Sinon,
on court à notre perte.
Il n'y aura plus d'électricité,e
de Phoenix sans électricité."
Phoenix, Los Angeles, Las Vegas
sans électricité, sans eau,
tout ceci semble inimaginable.
Les casinos en plein désert
carburent toujours à l'air
climatisée. On vit au rythme
des machines, dans des tours
réfrigérées, avec le mirage
d'une vie meilleur
Comme si la réalité extérieure
n'était finalement qu'un mauvais
cauchemar à oublier.
♪ ♪ ♪